the situation we face is clearly very
serious
perhaps the darkest moment of the
pandemic
the virus is out of control over a
million people in england
now have covered the number of hospital
admissions
is rising tragically so the numbers of
people
dying and it's only the early days of
january
and the nhs is under huge strain
in those circumstances tougher
restrictions are necessary
we will support them we will vote for
them
and urge everybody to comply with the
new rules
stay at home protect the nhs
save lives but this is not just
bad luck it's not inevitable
it follows a pattern in the first wave
of the pandemic the government was
repeatedly too slow to act
and we ended 2020 with one of the
highest death tolls in europe
and the worst hit economy of major
economies
in the early summer a government report
called preparing for a challenging
winter warned at the risk of a second
wave
of the virus mutating and of the nhs
being overwhelmed
it set out the preparations the
government needed to take
i put that report to the prime minister
at pmq's
in july throughout the autumn track and
trace didn't work
sage advised a circuit break in
september
but the prime minister delayed for weeks
before acting
we had a tiered system that didn't work
and then we had the debacle of the
delayed decision to change the rules
or mixing at christmas the most
recent advice about the situation we're
now in
was given on the 22nd of december but no
action was taken for two weeks
until monday of this week
mr speaker these are the decisions that
have led us to the position we are now
in
and the vaccine is now the only way out
and we must all support the national
effort to get it rolled out as quickly
as possible
we will do whatever we can to support
the government on this
we were the first country to get the
vaccine let's be the first country
to roll out that vaccine program but we
need a plan
to work to the promise has given some
indication
in the last few days but can he tell the
house exactly what the plan is
can the nhs deliver 2 million vaccines a
week
i think they can i hope they can but do
they have the resources and support
to do so and we will support that of
course
will there be sufficient doses available
week on week to get us to the 14 million
doses by mid-february what can we do
to help it's vital that that happens i'm
glad to hear that high street
pharmacists will be helping
can we use volunteers in support of this
national
effort let me turn to financial support
yesterday's announcement will help but
the british chamber of commerce and
others have already warned it's not
enough
there are big gaps and big questions
first
why is there still nothing to help the
three million self-employed who've been
excluded from the very start
that was unfair in march of last year
it was even more unfair in the autumn
it's totally
unforgivable now it may well be a whole
year that that group have gone without
any
meaningful support that gap needs to be
plugged
secondly will the prime minister drop
his plan to cut universal credit by 20
pounds a week
that needs to be done now and we will
support it
will he immediately end extend the
eviction ban
that's due to run out just in five days
time now just as we're going in
to this new phase third will he address
the obvious issues with financial
support
for those required to isolate including
statutory sick pay
and support for local councils and will
the prime minister finally recognize
that now is the worst possible time to
freeze pay for our key workers
yes schools we all
recognize the huge damage that closing
schools will cause for many children and
families
but the prime minister knew that
closures might be necessary
so there should always have been a
contingency plan
up to 1.8 million children don't have
access to a home computer
and 900 000 children live in households
that rely on mobile internet connections
so can the prime minister tell us when
is the government going to get the
laptops to those that need them
he's spoken about the 50 000 delivered
and the 100 000
more but 1.8 million children don't have
access
to a home computer so there's real
urgency needed now as we go into these
weeks
i welcome what the prime minister said
about telecoms companies
cutting the cost of online learning it's
vital that they do so
i'm assuming that's happening straight
away um because we can't delay there
and will the price be straight about
what's going to happen with exams this
year
we cannot leave this until months down
the line in particular
very pressing now for those who are
meant to be taking their btec exams in
the next few days
surely they must just be cancelled some
leadership on this
is desperately needed next
mr speaker our borders the prime
minister knows there's
real concern about the rapid
transmission of this disease
there are new strains being detected in
south africa denmark and elsewhere
the quarantine system isn't working the
prime minister said yesterday that
we will be bringing in extra measures at
the border
i have to ask why are those measures not
introduced already
they've been briefed to the media for
days but nothing has happened
mr speaker this is the third time the
country has been asked to close its
doors
we need to make sure it's the last we
will support the prime minister and the
government in these measures
we will carry the message and do
whatever is asked of us
but we will demand that the prime
minister keeps his side of the bargain
use this latest lockdown to support
families
protect businesses and get the vaccine
rolled out
as quickly and safely as possible thank
you mr speaker